my guys were here at the property
investors circle right now and we're
learning how to buy property without
investing any money sounds too good to
be true but there's a bunch of people
now but I only have to do it and I'll
find India I was checking out to Samuel
Leeds is property investor circle event
it's an awesome event because people are
so authentic and humble in this room and
it's a great place and supportive place
to really learn about property
understand how you can move forward in
your property journey I'd highly highly
recommend you go and attend anyway good
good good let's get back
lady Melissa I absolutely just enjoyed
the talk that he gave her the rent to
rent and it was heightened format just
really looking forward to going to
implement the information on even more
so yeah it was something different than
what I expected but I think it was very
employment if and I like the way he did
his presentation just having a little
bit of a networking session
out in the beautiful gardens where the
colder fields Golf Club people all over
the bar hanging out and have a real good
time so if you're not here and you want
to come in join us next time
you're very welcome we just tell it's a
ten-pound contribution fee to comment
down to learn about property and to
really get around people that will help
you to become financially free god bless
you hope seen it's time